this episode is a follow-up to our main
release with avi
loeb since our first interview with avi
the u.s government has released a new
report on ufos
otherwise now known as uaps this report
is titled preliminary assessment
unidentified aerial phenomena and so as
with our first episode with avi we
explored amoa moa
whether or not that might be alien in
origin we wanted to get him back on the
podcast to explore this report
ufos or uaps whether or not they might
be alien in origin
and what this all has to do with the
future of humanity and so with that i'm
happy to introduce this bonus content
with avi loeb
the office of the director of national
intelligence has
released a preliminary assessment on
unidentified aerial phenomena which is a
new word that they're using for
for ufo so now it's it's uap so
can you summarize the the contents of
this report and explain why the report
is significant
the most important statement made in the
report is that some of the objects that
were detected
uh are probably real and that is based
on the fact that they were detected in
multiple
instruments using radar systems
or infrared cameras or optical
visual cameras or
several military personnel seeing the
same thing doing the same thing at the
same time
and so that is a very significant
statement because the
immediate suspicion is that unusual
phenomena occur when you have a smudge
on your camera when you're
there is malfunction of some instruments
and the fact that there is
corroborating evidence among different
instruments
implies that it must be something real
happening
um so that's the first significant
statement and then there were 144
incidents documented but it was also
mentioned that
there is a stigma on reporting and
because there is a taboo on discussing
extraterrestrial
technologies and as a result only a
small minority of all
events were reported but nevertheless
the
navy established in march 2019 a
procedure for reporting which was not
available prior to that
and the air force followed on that in
december 2020 so
it's all very recent that um
there is this procedure or formal
a path through which reports can be
obtained and
of course that helps in the sense that
it provides a psychological
uh support system for those that want to
report about
unusual things they have witnessed and
prior to that they had
to dare to speak uh given the stigma
and so um the second
issue is of course uh we have objects if
some of them are real and
and by the way we only saw a small
fraction of the evidence
uh most of it is classified and the
reason is that the
government owns sensors that were used
to to obtain this evidence and uh
these sensors are being used to monitor
the sky and therefore our
national security importance and we
don't want to release
information about the quality of the
sensors to our adversaries to other
nations and so
the data itself is being classified
because the instruments are classified
but nevertheless one can think of
several possible interpretations of
these real objects
uh and i should say that cia directors
like brennan and woolsey and
former president barack obama spoke
about
these events as serious matters so that
to me it all implies that we need to
consider them seriously and so there are
several possible interpretations
one of course is that they are
human-made and
some other nation uh produced them but
the some of the objects behaved in ways
that
supersede our technologies the limits of
the technologies we have in the us and
uh
we have some intelligence in what other
nations are doing
and moreover if there was another nation
with
far better technologies they would find
themselves
in the consumer market because there
would be a huge financial benefit
to using them or we would see some
evidence for them in the
in the battlefield and at the moment we
have a
pretty good idea i would argue that as
to what other nations are doing
technologically speaking so
so if there are real objects behaving in
ways that exceed the
human technologies then the question is
what could it be and there are two
possibilities uh either it's
these are natural phenomena that occur
in the atmosphere that
we did not expect or
they are of extraterrestrial origin some
other
technological civilization produce these
objects
and deploy them here and uh of course
both of these possibilities are exciting
because we learn something new
so the message i take from this report
is that the evidence is sufficiently
intriguing
for the subject to move away from the
talking points of
politicians national security advisers
military personnel
that were really not trained as
scientists
it should move into the realm of science
where we use
state-of-the-art equipment such as
cameras installed on wide field
telescopes that scan the sky
and these are telescopes you can buy off
the shelf
and you can position them in similar
geographical locations and
monitor the sky with open data and
analyze the data using the best
computers we have
in a completely transparent way like a
scientific experiment
and so that's what we should do next
and instead what i see is that a lot of
scientists just ridicule
the significance of of the report or say
that
business as usual that there is no need
to attend
to its statements and i think it's an
opportunity for science to actually
clarify this matter and clear up the fog
and this is definitely a question that
is of great interest to the public what
is the nature of these unidentified
objects or phenomena are they natural in
origin or maybe extraterrestrial
and i'm very much willing to address
this
with my research group given proper
funding for it
let's stick here with this with this
first point right so um
i actually heard neil degrasse tyson on
um on msnbc
just before we started talking and
he was mentioning that he thought that
there could have been hardware or
software artifacts
that could have been generating these
um like generating artifacts
on these systems and i i think your
first point
very clearly refutes that because you
have multiple different systems plus
eyewitness reports all corroborating the
same thing
exactly so it's confusing to me why he
would
he why he would say that well because
uh he is trying to maximize the number
of likes he has on twitter and
doubting the reality of these reports
appears to be popular
among people in academia among
scientists
among some people in the public and so
he's driven by that my point is
an intelligent culture is driven
or actually
is following the the guiding principles
of science
and those are sharing evidence-based
knowledge
what neil degrasse tyson is doing is not
sharing evidence-based knowledge but
rather
dismissing evidence and
my point is this evidence that
is being reported in washington dc uh
is intriguing enough yeah to motivate us
to collect more evidence
rather than ignore it so obviously you
know
uh if you look at the history of science
we often make discoveries when
we find anomalies things that do not
line up
with what we expected and the best
example is quantum mechanics that was
discovered a century ago
nobody expected it it was forced upon us
by experiments and
actually albert einstein at the time
resisted one of its
fundamental facets uh entanglement or
or what he called spooky action at a
distance
that a quantum system uh knows
about its different parts even if they
are separated
by a large distance such that light
signals cannot propagate
over the time of the experiment and he
argued that this
is cannot be the case and wrote a paper
about it it's
uh but with his post docs
it's called the einstein podolski rosen
experiment the experiment was done and
demonstrated that
he was wrong and even a century later
you know we are still debating the
meaning of quantum mechanics so it's
sort of like a bond
stuck in the throat of physicists but
nevertheless we
we know that quantum mechanics holds and
applies to reality
uh and in fact the reason the two of us
are conversing is
because of our understanding of quantum
mechanics that the fact that we can use
it in in all the instruments that we use
for example the speaker that the two of
us are using and
the internet and the uh computers we are
using all of these
use principles of quantum mechanics that
were discovered over the years
over the century and my point is that
the very often when you do experiments
you know that there is
uh there are situations where you don't
you get something you don't expect and
that's part of the learning experience
and we should
respect deviations from our expectations
because they carve a new path to new
understanding new learning about
reality and about nature rather than
ridiculing it rather than always
thinking that
what we will find will match what we
expected
and so if the government among all
comes along with reports about unusual
phenomena
you know the government is very
conservative very often
you would expect the scientific
community to embrace that
as an exciting topic to investigate
because the government is saying
something let's figure out what is it
about
let's clarify the nature of these
phenomena that appear
anomalous rather than saying business as
usual i don't believe it it could be a
malfunction of the instrument
so if it is a malfunction of the
instrument why did many instruments show
the same thing why did many pilots show
the same thing
and i should clarify that in the
courtroom if
you have two eyewitness testimonies that
corroborate each other
you can put people in jail as a result
so we believe
people in in the legal system and
somehow when it comes to pilots you know
who are very serious people that serve
our country
then neil degrasse tyson dismisses their
testimony and
uh so my point is not that we must
believe it
but rather that we then it's intriguing
enough for us to collect more data and
evidence
and let's not express any judgment until
we collect that evidence and
you know if we the only scene we can
make is
basically ignore uh the reports and and
do business as usual
which is pretty much what he is
preaching for and
my point is no instead we should invest
funds
at a new experiment or experiments
that will shed more light on the nature
of these objects
so the the the second point that you you
made earlier
was that the government was establishing
a a framework and system for receiving
reports about ufos so
part of this and part of this document
is it true to say then
that there is also a confirmation that
the government does not know what these
are and that they are not
a secret u.s project
yeah they stated it explicitly in the
report they said that the
the data is not good enough the evidence
is not good enough
to figure out the nature of these
objects so we don't know what they are
and by the way you won't expect military
personnel or politicians to figure out
the nature of
anomalous objects because they were not
trained as scientists so
when you go to a shoemaker you wouldn't
expect the shoemaker to make you to bake
you a cake uh
they are not you know these are not
people that were trained to analyze
data of this type or to collect new data
such that
the uh nature of these objects will be
figured out
that is what scientists are supposed to
do and
that's why i'm advocating for moving
this subject away from washington dc
into an open discussion in the
scientific community where
we'll collect open data analyze it in a
transparent way
not with government-owned sensors and
or computers and and then it will be all
clear you know it's
it will be a transparent process uh we
don't need to rely on washington dc to
tell us
what appears in our sky the sky is
unclassified in most locations you know
we can look up anytime we want
and so we should do it so so with your
third point
um there's this consideration that
people are more likely to try and give a
conventional explanation
of uaps as coming from other countries
like russia or
china and you were explaining that there
are heavy commercial incentives
for example that if you had this kind of
technology
it could for example revolutionize your
economy
and you wouldn't just be using it to
[Music]
pester u.s navy pilots off the coast
right
like it could be used for for really
significant economical
reasons and so it seems like
that also counts as evidence against
it being conventional in origin or like
a secret government project
what is your perspective on that yes um
and it will not only find its place in
the consumer market but also in the
battlefield and
we have a sense of what other nations
are doing because
the us has its own intelligence and we
pretty much know what the status of
their science and technology is so it's
not as if we are completely in the dark
here
and i would argue that if the us
government
reports about these objects
there is good evidence that they are not
made by those other nations because
if our intelligence would tell us that
there were
potentially made by other nations then
we would try to develop the same
technologies ourselves
uh and another way to put it is
if a scientific inquiry into the nature
of these objects
allows us to get a high resolution
photograph of one of them
and then we see the label made in china
or made in the ussr
on it made in russia
then we would realize that there was a
major
failure of national intelligence and
that would be
a very important conclusion of course
that would have implications
for our national security but i doubt
that this is the case because we have
some knowledge
of what other nations are doing and then
the data would not have been released
this way in this
kind of a report if there was suspicion
that these objects are human-made
so the report makes clear then that it's
not u.s
technology and there are also reasons
that count against it being for example
russian or chinese technology
because the incentives are aligned for
them to just deploy it already
and use it in the public sector
so before we get into more specifics
about
about thinking about whether or not
these are
human or extraterrestrial in origin i'm
curious if you could explain a bit more
of the
flight and capability characteristics of
these uaps and ufos
and what what you feel are the most
significant reports
of them in their activity well i didn't
have
direct access to to the data especially
not the the classified one and i would
very much
want to see the full data set before
expressing an opinion but
at least some of the videos that were
shown indicated
motions that cannot be reproduced by
the kind of crafts that we own
but the the what i would like to know
is whether when the object moves faster
than the speed of sound for example in
air whether it produces a sonic boom a
shock wave that we see for example when
jets
do the same because that would be an
indication that indeed there is a
physical object that is
compressing air as it moves around or if
it moves through water
i want to see the splash of water and
from that i can infer
some physical properties and of course i
would like to have
a very high resolution image of the
object so that i can see if it has
screws if it
if there is something written on it um
either made in china or made on planet x
either messages would be of great
importance
so what i'm really after is access to
the best data that we have and obviously
it will not be released from the
government because the best data is
probably classified
but i would like to collect it uh
through using scientific instrumentation
which by the way could be far better
uh than the instruments that were uh on
airplanes that the pilots were using
or on navy ships because these were
designed to be
in combat situations and they were not
the optimal
for analyzing such objects
and we can do much better if we
choose our scientific instruments
carefully and design the experiment in a
way that would reproduce the results
with a much higher fidelity of the data
there's there's so much about this that
is uh
similar to omoamoa in terms of their
being
you know just barely and like the
imaging is not quite enough to really
know what it is and then there being
lots of
interesting evidence that counts for for
extraterrestrial in
in origin is is that a perspective you
share
well yes i wrote a scientific american
article where i said
you know one thing we know about omoamo
is that it probably had a flat
shape pancake-like and also
if it's push away from the sun was a
result of reflecting sunlight
it must have been quite thin and the
size of a football field
and in that case you know i thought
maybe it serves as a light sail but
potentially it could also be a receiver
uh intended to detect information or
signals uh from probes that were
sprinkled on planets in the habitable
zone around the sun so
if for example the uap are probes
transmitting signals then the passage of
such a receiver
near earth was meant to
obtain that information and and omua moa
for example was tumbling
every eight hours was looking in all
directions in principle for such signals
so
that could be one interpretation that it
was thin not because it was a light cell
but it
because it served a different purpose
and in september 2020 we saw another
object that also
exhibited an excess push away from the
sun by reflecting sunlight
and had no cometary tail it was given
the name 2020so
and it was a rocket booster from a 1966
mission
had thin walls uh for a completely
different purpose
not not having anything to do with
with it being a light sail so i
would argue that perhaps a moomoo had
these weird properties
because it served a different purpose
and that's why
you know we should both try to get
a better image of an object like omomoa
and
of the unidentified objects we find
closer to earth
and in both cases a high resolution
photograph
is better than a thousand words in my
case better than
66 000 was the number of words in my
book
yeah it's the the in both cases a little
bit better instrumentation would have
seemingly made a huge difference so
let's um let's pivot into
again this area of conventional
explanations
and so we talked a little bit earlier
about one conventional explanation
being that this is some kind of
you know advanced secret military
technology of china
or or russia that's used for probing our
aerial defenses and the the argument
that counts against that again
was that there are you know military and
economic incentives to deploy it more
fully
especially because the flight
characteristics that these objects are
expressing are so much greater than
anything that america has in terms of
the speed and the agility so
in so so one theory is that instead of
the technology being actual like they
actually have the technology
that goes that fast and is that agile
that this is actually some form
of spoofing technology so some kind of
way
of an adversary training electronic
counter measures
to simulate or emulate or create the
illusion of
[Music]
what we witnessed uh in in in terms of
the us
instruments so do you think that such an
explanation
is is viable i mean it's possible and
that's why we need more data but
um it's not easy to produce
an illusion uh in multiple instruments
say both
radar uh infrared and optical sensors
because
uh you know you can probably create an
illusion for
one one of these sensors uh but then for
all of them it would require a great
deal of
uh ingenuity and then
you would need a good reason to do that
you know why would the other nations
engage in
deceiving us in this way uh for 20 years
i mean that would look a bit
and also we would have probably found
something some clue about them
trying to do that you know because they
would have
trained such probes or such objects
first uh in their own facilities and
we would see some evidence for that so i
find it hard to believe i would think
it's either some natural phenomena that
we haven't yet
experienced or suspected or
it's this unusual possibility of an
extraterrestrial origin
uh and either way we will learn
something new by exploring it more
we should not then have any prejudice we
should not dismiss it that would be the
worst we can do just dismiss it and
ridicule it and
as usual because actually you know it's
exciting to
try and figure out a puzzle that's what
the detectives
often do and uh i just don't understand
the spirit of dismissing it and
not looking into it at all
so you just mentioned um
that you thought that it might have some
kind of natural explanation
like there are very strange things in
nature
um i'm not sure if this is for example
real or not but there's like
there's a wikipedia page for example for
ball lightning
um and there's also like really weird
uh phenomena that you can have in the
sky
if like the lighting in the sky is just
right and where the sun is where you get
weird halos and things
right um and you know throughout history
there are reports of
like mass reports of like dancing lights
in the sky
or or things that might have been
collective
hallucinations are actually real so um
in terms of it being something natural
that we understand or being something
human made that we're not aware of what
to you
is the most convincing natural or
conventional explanation
of these objects uh an explanation that
is not extraterrestrial in origin
well um if if it's dancing lights
it wouldn't produce a radar echo
so as i said i don't have access to the
data
in each and every incident but
there are some fundamental uh
logic that one can use for each of these
data sets and
figure out if it could be an illusion
uh if not if it must be a real object
somehow nature has to produce a real
object
that behaves this way and until i get
my own data and reproduce those um
i won't make any statement uh but i'm
optimistic that
uh you know given the appropriate
investment of funds which
i'm currently discussing with the
private sector
funders uh that we can do it and
just to give you an example if you
wanted to get
a high resolution image like a megapixel
image of a one meter size object at a
distance of a kilometer
uh you just need a one meter telescope
for that and
observing it at optical light and you
will be able to see
millimeter size features on it like the
head of a pin
so um in prince i mean people ask why
didn't we see it already in iphone
images of the sky well
the iphone camera is a millimeter
or a few millimeters in aperture size
and
it's too small you can you can't get
anything better than a fuzzy image of a
very distant
object so you really need to have a
dedicated experiment
and i i think one can do it and i'm
happy to engage in that
you would also wonder that these things
are
probably so if they if they were
extraterrestrial in origin you would
expect that they would be
pretty intelligent and that they might
understand
what our sensor capabilities are um
so yeah i think perhaps that might count
as evidence um
you know for why given that there are
billions of camera phones around the
planet that there aren't any
any good pictures yeah what's effective
on that
so um if i had to guess i would
think of these systems as
equipped with artificial intelligence uh
we already have
systems of artificial intelligence that
are capable of
uh you know that are capable of
um superseding human abilities and
within a decade
uh they will be more intelligent than
people who will be able to
learn through machine learning and adapt
to changing circumstances and behave
very intelligently so
in fact i can imagine that if another
civilization
had a technological development of more
than a century more than we did
they could have produced systems that
are autonomous
uh there is it doesn't make any sense to
communicate with the sender because the
nearest star is four light years away
takes four years for a signal to reach
even the nearest star and it takes tens
of thousands of years to reach the
end of the galaxy the milky way and so
there is no sense of a piece of
equipment communicating with its senders
in order to get guidelines as to what to
do instead it should be autonomous it
has its own
intelligence and it could outsmart us
we already almost have such systems so
in fact
we may need to use our own artificial
intelligence systems
in order to interpret the actions of
those
artificial intelligence systems so it
will resemble the experience of asking
our children to interpret the content
that we find on the internet because
they have
better computer skills we need our
computers to tell us what their
computers are doing
and that's the way i think about it and
these systems could be so intelligent
that they do things that are subtle
they don't appear and start a
conversation
with us they are sort of gathering
information of interest to them
and acting in a way that reflects the
blueprint
that the guided whoever created them
and the question is what is their agenda
what is their intent
and that will take us a while to figure
out we have to see what kind of
information they are seeking
how do they respond to our actions and
eventually we might want to engage with
them but
the point is many people think of
contact as being a very sort of abrupt
and the
interaction of
extraordinary proportion that is
impossible to deny
but in fact it could be very subtle
because they're very intelligent if you
look at
intelligent humans
they're not aggressive they're often
thinking about everything they do and
and select their actions appropriately
they don't get into
very violent confrontations often so
so let's see what we need to rely on
evidence
rather than prejudice and the biggest
mistake we can
make is the mistake made by philosophers
during the days of galileo
they said we don't want to look through
a telescope because we know that the
sun moves around the earth we spoke a
little bit earlier about uh
bayesian reasoning and omoamoa um
do you have the same feelings about not
having priors about
it being at the the uaps being
extraterrestrial or
human in in origin or is is there a
credence that you're
you're able to assign to um it being
extraterrestrial in origin the situation
is even better in the context of
uap because they are
here not far from us and we can do the
experiment
uh with a rather modest budget
and therefore i think we can resolve
this
issue with no need to have a prejudice
you know often you need the
prior if the effort requires
extraordinary funds so you have to say
okay is it really worth
investing those funds but my point is
that finding the answer to the nature of
uap may cost us much less
than we already spent in the search for
dark matter
we haven't found anything we don't know
what the dark matter is
we spend hundreds of millions of dollars
and
at a cost lower than that maybe by an
order of magnitude
we can try and figure out the nature of
uap
so given the price tag
let's not make any assumptions let's
just do it and figure it out
if these are extraterrestrial in origin
one might expect that
they are here for probing or information
gathering
and so you said there are reports going
back
20 years if they are extraterrestrial in
origin who knows how long
they've been here they could have been
you know sent out
through nanoscale
shots out into the cosmos that land and
then grow and replicate
on some planet and act as
act as scouts so um if this were the
case
that they were here as as information
gathering probes
one might wonder why they don't use much
more advanced
technology so for example why not use
nanotechnology that we would have
no hope of detecting um they're in one
report for example though
the pilot explains it like uh following
him
and they're kind of like uh it comes
right in front of him and then it
disappears
so that disappearing
seems a bit more like magic right any
sufficiently powerful technology is
indistinguishable to magic to
a less advanced civilization um but
the other characteristics seem maybe
like 100 or 200
years away of human technological
advancement so what's up with that
well yeah so for us to figure out what's
going on we need
uh date more data and it may well be
that there are lots of things happening
that we haven't yet
realized because they are done in a way
that is very subtle that we cannot
really detect easily
because our technologies are quite
limited to the century and a half that
we developed them
so you're right there may be a hidden
reality that
we are not aware of but we are seeing
traces of things that
attract our attention that's why when we
see something intriguing
we should dig into that you know it
could be clues for something that we
have never
imagined so
for example if you were to present a
cell phone to a caveman
obviously the cell phone would be
visible to the caveman
and the caveman would think oh it's
probably a rock a shiny rock
so the the caveman will recognize
part of reality that there is an object
reflecting light
that is a bit more shiny than a typical
rock because the caveman is used to
playing with rocks
but the caveman initially at least will
not figure out
the features on the cell phone and the
fact that
he can speak to other people through
this rock
and that's what will take us a while to
be
educated about and the question is you
know
among the things that are happening
around us you know
which fraction are we aware of
as with the correct interpretation and
maybe we are not
if these uaps or a moammoa itself
or some new interstellar object that we
were able to find
were fairly conclusively shown to be
extraterrestrial technology what do you
think our response
should be it seems like on one hand this
would clearly potentially be an
existential threat
which then makes it relevant to the
future of life institute
on the other hand it's likely that we
could do nothing to
counter such a threat like we couldn't
even counter
humanity probably 50 years from now if
we
had to defend ourselves against the 50
year old wiser more technologically
advanced version of ourself
and on cosmological time scales you
would expect that
you know even a thousand two thousand
year lead would be pretty common
but also you know indefensible
um so
there's a sense that also an attack an
antagonistic attitude would
probably make things worse but also that
we couldn't do anything so
how would how do you think humanity
should react right so
um the question of intent is indeed the
the next question after you identify an
object
that appears to be of extraterrestrial
technological origin
and we should all remember the story
about the trojan horse
that looked very innocent to the
citizens of troy but ended up serving a
different purpose and
that of course implies that we should
collect as much evidence as possible
about
the objects that we find at first and
see
how they behave what kind of information
they're seeking
uh how do they respond to our actions
and ultimately we might want to engage
with them but
um i should mention that if you look at
human history
nations that they traded with each other
benefited much more than nations that
went into war with each other
uh and so a truly intelligent
species might actually prefer to
benefit from the interaction with us
rather than kill us or destroy us
and then perhaps take advantage of the
resources
use whatever we are able to provide them
with
so it's possible that there are
initially just spectators trying to
figure out
uh what are what are the things that
they can benefit from and
but from our perspective we should
obviously be
suspicious and careful and we should
speak in one voice you know humanity as
a whole there should be an international
organization
perhaps related to the united nations or
some other
entity that makes decisions about
how to interact with whatever we find
and
we don't want the one nation to respond
in a way that would not represent
all of humanity because that could
endanger all of us
and in that the forum that makes
decisions about how to
respond there should be of course
physicists that figure out
the physical properties of these these
objects
and there should be policy makers that
uh can think about how you know how best
to
interact with these these objects so
you also mentioned earlier that you were
talking with private funders
about um potentially
coming up with an action plan or a
project
for getting more evidence and data
on these these objects so i guess
there's a two-part question here
i'm curious if you could explain a
little bit about what that project is
about
and more generally what can the
scientific uh
non-governmental and amateur hobbyist
communities
do to help investigate these these
phenomena
so are there productive ways for citizen
scientists and interested listeners to
contribute to the efforts to better
understand uaps
well my hope is to get a high resolution
photograph it's a very simple thing to
desire
uh we're not talking about some deep
philosophical questions here if we had
a megapixel image an image with a
million
resolution elements of an object
if it has a size of emitter that would
mean that each pixel is a millimeter
in size the size of the head of a pin
you can pretty much see all the details
on the object and
try and figure out reverse engineer what
it's
meant to do and whether it's human-made
or not
so you know even a kid can understand my
ambition
it's not very complicated just get a
megapixel image
of such an object that's it they seem
common enough that it wouldn't be
too difficult if the well the issue is
not how common they are but
what device you are using to image them
because if you use an iphone
the aperture on the iphone will give you
only a fuzzy image what you need is a
meter
size telescope collecting the
information and resolving
uh an object of emitter size at a
distance of a kilometer
down to a millimeter uh resolution
right right i mean that the navy pilots
for example have reported seeing them
every day for years so if oh yeah if we
had such a device then you wouldn't have
to wait too long
exactly exactly get a really good
picture so that's my point um
if these are real objects we can resolve
them
and that's what i want to have a high
resolution image that's all and it will
not be classified because it's being
taken by off-the-shelf
instruments uh it the data will be open
and
here comes the role that can be played
by amateurs
once the data is available to the public
anyone can analyze it
nothing is classified about the sky uh
we can all look up and
if i i get that the high resolution
image
believe me that everyone will be able to
look at it so as we start to
to wrap up here um do you have a
favorite science fiction book
and what is some of your favorite
science fiction ideas
well my favorite film his arrival
and in fact i admired this film long ago
but
a few months ago the producer of that
film had a zoom
session with me to tell me how much he
liked my book
extraterrestrial and i told him i
admired your
film long before you read my book and
the reason i like this film is because
it deals with a deep philosophical
question of how to communicate
with an alien culture and in fact even
the medium through which the
communication takes place
in the film is unusual and
you know the the challenge is similar to
code breaking
sort of like uh the project that alan
turing
led during the second world war of the
enigma trying to figure out
to break the code of of the nazis
so if you have some signal and you want
to figure out the meaning of it
uh it's actually a very complex
challenge depending on
how the information is being encoded and
and i think you know the film addresses
it in a very
genuine and original fashion and i liked
it a lot
so do you have any last minute thoughts
or anything you'd just really like to
communicate to the uh
the audience and the public about uaps
these reports and the need to collect
more evidence and data for figuring out
what they are
my hope is that with a high resolution
image
we will not only learn more about the
nature of uap
but change the culture
of the discourse on this subject
and then i think that such an image
would
uh convince uh even the skeptics even
people that are currently ridiculing it
to join the discussion the serious
discussion
about what all of this means and
if there are any private funders or
philanthropists
listening that are interested in
contributing to the project
to capture this data how is it best that
they get in contact with you
well they can just send me an email to
aloeb
cfa.harvard.edu and
i will be delighted to add them to the
group of funders that are currently
showing interest in it all right thank
you very much avi
thank you for having me
[Music]
you